meine tipps so sparen sie mit
schnäppchen blogs zum beispiel mai
topdeals schnäppchen fuchs oder auch bei
deals das sind wirklich sehr sehr
interessante portale sollten sie mal
drauf schauen tipp 1 diese webseiten
sind verführung pur das heißt also mein
tipp wirklich kaufen sie nur das was sie
brauchen und nicht weil es billig ist
tipp 2 die preisrecherche auf solchen
blocks ist wirklich sehr seriöse und
wird auch von den usern auch
gegengecheckt also tatsächlich war es
dasteht ist wirklich dann auch günstig
und wird auch natürlich in den
kommentaren auch als günstig bewertet
tipp3 ausverkäufe sind natürlich überall
möglich das heißt also wenn etwas
besonders preiswert ist schlagen sie
lieber gleich zu sie können es am ende
vielleicht doch wieder zurückgeben aber
solche schnäppchen sind oft sehr
vergriffen
tipp 4 vorsicht manche post sind werbung
und sie sind gar nicht so wahnsinnig
billig sondern die stehen halt oben weil
der betreiber der website dafür geld
bekommt tipp 5
tatsächlich werden sie direkt von den
schnäppchen box direkt in die online
shops gehen da verschenken sie
möglicherweise bonuspunkte deswegen mein
tipp lieber über die bonus portale wie
zum beispiel payback oder
deutschlandcard oder auch schub wirklich
auf den shop gehen dann heimsen sie da
auch noch bonuspunkte ein und reduziert
dann letztlich indirekt den preis
weiterhin